challenge Joe Biden and you're a racist
Democrat Dean Phillips learning that
lesson the hard way after launching his
campaign against the big guy South
Carolina Congressman Jim klyburn doing
Joe's Dirty Work and accusing Phillips
of disrespecting
African-Americans saying quote black
voters are an essential piece of the
democratic Coalition and any candidate
for president of the United States ought
to know and respect their pivotal role
in how Democrats win national elections
there's too much at stake to pay
attention to this kind of silly
now that's got to sting Phillips trying
to smooth things over with kurn but the
damage has been done I'm disappointed Mr
kurn a man I admire and respect uh knows
better and that's exactly the political
conversation that is dividing the
country right now those who are
participating in dividing by casting
blame and Shadow on people like me
that's part of the problem I have
respect for Mr kurn but I think that's
exactly what's
wrong do you think everything's is cool
now you mean between Dean Phillips
between all of us know the so look I've
known Jim clber in a really long time
and he's a dear friend I I don't I don't
he's one of the guys that I think that
don't doesn't always inject race into
things I I do think that I hope he and
Dean Phillips get together and figure
this out and I hope one of the things
you have to do if you're going to run
for president you got to have a vision
you got to have a message you got to
have an agenda you got to be able to
connect with voters you got to be able
to raise money uh and black voters are
the most reliable voters in the
Democratic party and frankly the ones
that have straightened us out when when
it looked like someone to take us too
far left we got Biden and Clinton
because black voters said hey you can't
you can't go too far the left um South
Carolina's first I think people New
Hampshire are upset about that if I were
Dean Phillips I get the political
strategy go to place where the president
won't show up and where people are angry
with him uh but both of them can be
right I don't think that Dean Phil I
don't know him he doesn't strike me as a
guy that where race it preoccupies his
mind he strikes me as a guy that's
pursuing a political strategy but I got
a message for him too you won't be
president you won't get the Democratic
nomination if black voters don't know
you and don't understand what you want
to do not only for them but for the
country hopefully they can sit down and
figure this out Dana does it show that
maybe Joe's not as strong as he should
be if his guy clyburn's dealing with
someone that's pulling it less than 1%
Joe Biden is definitely not is not as
strong as he should be going into
re-election at this point that does not
look good Kellan could speak to that a
little bit more with with more Authority
than I can but as she pointed out he's
at 22% approval rating on an issue like
immigration in the tank on there's no
issue that I think that he's positive on
except for possibly the Ukraine war but
that's at 52% so the other problem is
Joe Biden let his campaign people try to
run rough shot over New Hampshire
without working it out first and now
they are set up for embarrassment that's
just the way they worked there was not a
way for them to stop New Hampshire from
being the first Primary in the nation
there wasn't a legal apparatus to do
that they didn't set it up so now they
are in a position where New Hampshire's
like no we are going first Biden chose
this fight and he looks like he's going
to lose it Greg I know you've been
following this very closely uh this is
the first time I've ever heard of Dean
Phillips what college does he run look
would someone calls you racist it's not
about a debate it's designed to make you
Retreat to scare you it's the basis for
every pernicious ill that is plaguing
America today you want to reduce crime
you're racist you want a strong border
you're racist you know you want school
choice you must be racist you want to
end homelessness racist so it's just and
in fact that actual activity preserves
racism because it actually hurts the
minorities that the person screaming
racism claims to protect so he just
wanted to scare this guy away that's all
it is and how can you be racist by
challenging a white president a white
president who attended the funeral of a
KKK leader a white president who said to
blacks you ain't for Jo you ain't black
if you ain't for Joe or whatever that is
you know I agree he knows better see I
said it that is so racist that is so
racist kellyanne here are some facts Joe
Biden came in fifth in New Hampshire he
got 8% of the vote last time he's not
even on the ballot this time he's a
sitting president he came in fourth in
Iowa got 16% of the vote there and then
he went to South Carolina and won
because Congress and chairman kurn uh
helped him do that and supported him but
by Senator by Congressman kurn's own
definition Joe Biden's a racist why did
he run in 2020 when he got in a black
man's way Cory Booker a black and Indian
woman's way kamla Harris is he a
homophobe because he got in the way of
our first wouldbe openly gay president
Pete Buddha judge mayor Pete he's even
he was even Joe Biden in running as the
white cisgender liberal rich guy uh he
got in the way of the American San in
the race and just as a reminder that was
Tulsi Gabbert not Elizabeth Warren so he
even got in the way of Julian Castro
who's that a Hispanic man who ran for
president so by kurn's own definition
Joe Biden is racist for for running I
think the biggest problem is not Dean
Phillips I think the biggest problem is
that an increasing number of non- colge
educated non-white voters are migrating
to the Republican party and they're
doing that because of the economy
they're doing that because of the Border
they're doing that because of law
enforcement they're also doing it
because of Education School and Charters
and also they're doing it because the
open hostility toward religion by this
Democratic party it's a big mistake for
the Democrats to do that but the biggest
problem is not Dean Phillips it's that
Joe Biden is going to have a very hard
time inspiring 81 million voters again
can I just say i' agree with everything
you said's going to declare go I think I
think cly's only point is that
Congressman Phillips should come to
South Carolina and campaign with black
voters I think that's his only point and
that's why when are you going to declare
Harold stop it his big point was that
somebody else shouldn't be running and
exposing the fact that your party that
used to elevate and elect young
Outsiders like Jimmy Carter and Barack
Obama and Bill Clinton are now stuck
with a guy who's every minute of 80 what
will Clyburn say about Nome I wait hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else